One of the most controversial and often
maligned mechanics anywhere in the
commander format is eminence. Eminence
is a keyword officially on five
legendary creatures and unofficially on
a sixth. And its effect is simple. It
lets one line of text on a commander
also work while the card is in the
command zone. So Sedar Jabari of Zafir's
first line of text allows you to loot,
to draw, and discard whenever you attack
with one or more knights. And this
happens regardless of whether he himself
is on the battlefield or in the command
zone. Then he has another line of text
that only applies while he's on the
field and plays off the eminence line,
reanimating a night creature whenever he
deals combat damage to an opponent. This
is how all six of the eminence creatures
work. There will be the eminence ability
that helps the deck a bit earlier in the
game, and then the commander will be a
sort of follow-up to that once played,
amplifying the advantage gained by the
eminence ability. If you're somebody
who's totally new to the keyword, this
could seem like a pretty reasonable sort
of ability structure. A relatively
unobjectionable way for a commander to
be designed. And in this video, I'm
going to argue just that. Mostly,
eminence is a largely fine keyword that
I would like to see again in some form.
And its bad reputation is primarily due
to some questionable design decisions on
Wizards of the Coast's part when they
designed some of the original Eminence
cards. There are a lot of places I could
start my daring defense, but I'm going
to start with two interesting things
that happened this year. In May, Attra
Prader's voice lost her position as the
most popular commander. Then last month,
she lost her position as the second most
popular commander as well. What replaced
her was the dragon and Edgar Marov, both
commanders with the keyword eminence. If
you're unfamiliar with these, you're
probably asking, what could these
commanders do to make them this popular?
And let's start there. Edgar Marov's
eminence ability reads, "Whenever you
cast another vampire spell, create a 1-
one black vampire creature token." More
mid-powered Edgar decks will typically
run a wide range of different mana
values and enjoy the extra vampire every
turn or two. Whereas higherpowered Edgar
decks will blast the table with an
endless wave of low-cost vampires to
take advantage of the complete lack of
any restriction on Eddie's eminence
ability, as well as the plentiful gooffs
Mardu vampires has access to. Edgar the
playable creature is a six- mana 44 with
first strike and haste that gives all
your vampires a plus one plus1 counter
when he attacks. Not a bad effect, but
certainly not something most Edgar
players will be rushing to spend six
mana to get. What about the dragon, the
current most popular commander? His
Eminence ability simply reads, "Your
other dragon spells cost one less to
cast." Unlike Edgar Marov, the dragon's
creature form is quite good if you have
the mana for it. With him being a nine-
mana 10-10 flyer with the ability,
whenever one or more dragons you control
attack, draw that many cards, then you
may put a permanent card from your hand
onto the battlefield. This collective
package doesn't require much
explanation. The eminence ability is a
powerful mana discount for dragons, and
the field ability is a powerful value
engine with dragons, collectively
producing the two primordial resources
for generically playing the game as a
dragon deck. So, these are our two most
popular commanders at present day.
They're also controversial and disliked
by a lot of players, particularly Edgar
Marov. I am among those players, and I
don't think either of these cards should
have been printed in the form they were.
However, the reasons why these cards are
seen as problematic by me and some other
players are complicated and have layers
to them. The simplest answer is because
they're powerful, and I actually would
consider this a major feature in what
makes these cards problematic. However,
power alone doesn't make a commander an
issue. Cece Weatherlight Captain is one
of the most powerful commanders in the
game, but I don't think most people
would consider her any sort of problem.
She operates in a unique way and within
a niche that has other good options for
players who want a different play style,
and her CEDH variants don't tend to
bleed play patterns into casual in the
same way some other commanders do. So,
what makes these weaker commanders more
of an issue by comparison? One of these
is simple. Being associated with an
iconic creature type imbuss them with a
natural casual commander aura. A tutor
engine like sis obviously feels weird at
a table of precons, but that big old
dragon deck might pass the vibe check
just fine. This is the classic feature
of a pub stomper commander. Not strictly
being powerful, but being out of place,
easily wriggling its way into games it
might not really belong in. Another
power associated issue I'd identify with
these is something I alluded to when I
was talking about ce earlier. These two
crowd other commanders out of lanes.
Dragons and vampires are two of the most
iconic Magic the Gathering creature
types and they're naturally going to be
popular choices for players new to the
commander format. The issue then is that
both of these commanders ended up being
by far the strongest option for their
creature type. And that fact then pushed
any new dragon or vampire player looking
for a shortcut to a strong deck to get
there by paying a lot of money for the
singular strongest commander. Edgar
Marov spent four years over the $50 mark
and the dragon spent two years at a
similar price with both of their peak
periods corresponding with the surge in
the popularity of the commander format
that started in late 2020. Initially the
connection with eminence might seem
pretty surface level. A powerful
eminence card takes over a creature type
and a weaker eminence card might not do
this. But this misses a key feature
which is how eminence interacts with
colors. See the dragon's color identity
is part of its issue. If dragon had the
same eminence text but was motto red or
even red blue, suddenly that's an actual
niche. Bladewing could have stayed the
black red choice. Atark could have
stayed the red green choice. And the
ever funky scion of the dragon could
have stayed the choice for players who
wanted all five colors. But if you
instead make a fivecolor option that's
dramatically better than the others. And
if that power doesn't even require
casting the card, you destroy a lot of
the reason to consider other options.
Even if you don't want to play with a
fivecolor mana base, the discount alone
makes dragon already better than most of
the other options, even if it's never
cast. The same goes for Edgar. Vampires
are traditionally mono black, followed
by black red, followed by black white.
If Edgar had been put into the
relatively unexplored in 2017 color
identity of black white, suddenly
vampire players would have a choice
between the more established vampire
identity of black red and the newer
Ixelon centered identity of black white
with this spicy new commander. Instead,
both of these are slurped up by Edgar.
And the fact that most of his power is
in his eminence ability means that
players don't even need to try to be in
three colors. Just stick him at the head
of your black red vampire deck and cast
him when you draw your command tower and
bing bang boom, your deck just received
a strict upgrade. To be clear, I don't
think it's wrong for Wizards of the
Coast to have wanted big powerful
uniting options with lots of colors to
hand out to some iconic creature types.
However, Eminence has some unique
problems in fitting this role. And for
this reason, I would lean toward two
colors or less on Eminence commanders as
a rule, especially if they're in a niche
where they risk overshadowing other
options. I might have even done this
with the more recently printed Sedar
Jabari of Zafir, which works with
knights, though at least that one has a
better balance between the power of the
eminence ability and the power of the
castable creature. Now, it might sound
like this niche element being tied to
iconic creature types is a big part of
my problem with Edgar and the air
dragon. And in a sense, it is, but tying
Eminence to cards with a creature type
actually accomplishes an important goal.
Increasing the specificity of Eminence
abilities. See, having an effect baked
into your gameplay for free is pretty
potent. Some players might find it
inherently problematic, and my personal
opinion is that those players are
underestimating the sheer power that a
traditional command zone can offer a
deck. But still, getting an effect
without paying for it is certainly
notable, and it's important that this
effect is specific so as to contain how
out of hand it can get. This is true for
both the trigger of the eminence ability
and for the payoff of it. Ideally, it
should be a specific trigger that
provides a specific output. But if
you're going to make one a bit more
general, you really need to crank up the
specificity of the other. Let's take the
example of an eminence ability that gets
this right in my book, that of Arabo,
Roar of the World. On paper, this
ability is by no means weak. Giving plus
3 plus 3 to a creature every combat step
from the very first turn of the game is
quite powerful, allowing for some hefty
beatdown early and amplifying later
damage done with various effects that
play off of damage dealt. However, this
effect, in addition to typically falling
under the generally less problematic
aggro archetype, is specific. It's an
effect that makes a cat more powerful at
attacking. There's a couple double
strike cats and a singular infect cat
that will offer the occasional early
kill on a blockerless opponent, but with
the cat limitation, you don't have
access to a whole lot of cards that
would be powerful if they were a lot
bigger on an early turn. This
specificity counterintuitively has a
diversifying effect on the play patterns
of Arabo decks. Rather than being allin
on taking advantage of the plus three
plus three buff on turns two to four
when it's the most powerful Arabo
players need to devise ways to make use
of the effect more holistically
throughout the game. And this can take a
variety of different forms. Arabo's
eminence is also uniquely interactable
among eminence commanders. A sorcery
speed plus 3 plus3 pump doesn't
typically do anything until creatures
are making contact during combat which
leaves ample opportunity to interact
with it. I like this design for Arabo,
but you may have noticed that I did say
uniquely interactable. All other
Eminence abilities are easier to get
value with, with Sedar Jabari only
requiring attacking with knights, Inala
only requiring wizards to enter, and the
other three being almost entirely
impossible to stop the effects of. This
uninteractability is another point of
critique that you'll most commonly find
from the removal lovers of the world.
These commanders all have effects that
can't even be gotten rid of by dusting
them with a sword supply shares. Now,
I'll lay my cards on the table here and
say that in principle, this feature of
Eminence doesn't strictly bother me.
There are lots of things that can't be
interacted with. Barring hard stacks
pieces, drawing a card at start of turn,
playing lands, untapping permanence, and
so forth. This game is also full of
hexroof creatures, uncounterable spells,
and abilities that can't even be
responded to. Setting aside these more
specific examples, it's also important
to remember that deleting opposing stuff
doesn't need to be the end- all beall of
EDH. And I find that this intense focus
on spot removal tends to indicate a lack
of creativity from players. A couple
months ago, I discussed on a second
channel video that I actually enjoy not
having many tools to deal with very
large creatures in one of my decks, as
it forces me to think harder with my
attacks and utilize the deck's more
aggressive tools in some situations.
This is a game with many axes on which
to attack opposing resources, whether
that be board, hand, library, life
total, or the stack. And it's good to be
willing to move outside your comfort
zone sometimes among those different
options. Now, does all of this mean the
uninteractability of eminence creatures
is never a problem? No. And in practice,
this feature of eminence can be a real
pain point for players, with Edgar Marov
being one of the more egregious examples
of an eminence ability feeling bad due
to its uninteractability.
His Eminence ability triggers on cast
for a card type with lots of great
lowcost options any number of times per
turn. If I'm at a low life total and I
counter two vampire spells that the
Edgar player plays, they still get the
two tokens. If they have a source of
haste, Edgar's in red, remember these
vampires can attack immediately. And
these easy to obtain and hard to prevent
one ones aren't just creatures to attack
and block with. Vampires as a type have
a bunch of really powerful cards that
take advantage of the raw number of
vampires in play, most of which can only
be prevented with a counter spell. And
that's to say nothing of the blood
artists and other aristocrats tools that
powerful Eddie decks tend to be crammed
with. An eminence ability that grants
creature tokens for casting spells was
always going to be a little tricky to
pull off regardless of creature type.
And that ability being for vampires in a
deck with black puts it fully over the
line into dangerous territory. The
tokens are too easy to get and there's
too many things that can be done with
them. In this extended discussion of how
Edgar plays, the point I'm trying to
make is that the frustrating play
patterns of him and some other eminence
commanders are the result of specific
design choices, not a problem with the
eminence mechanic as a whole. Gavin Verh
who worked on the design for Edgar Marov
and other eminence cards has said that
future Eminence designs should avoid
generating permanent onboard material
for players. I personally would set a
similar but somewhat broader rule. The
difficulty and specificity of the setup
needs to match the power of the payoff.
If triggering an eminence ability is
easy, the payoff should be less generic
and require more ingenuity to take
advantage of, as is the case with Allo
and to a lesser extent, Inala. If an
eminence ability has a stronger and more
generic payoff, it should have a
triggering condition that is more
specific or more preventable, as is true
of Arabo. When in doubt, designers
should go more specific with both of
these things. Relating back to Gavin's
view, giving players something like a
creature token or a treasure token is an
exceptionally generic payoff, and
engineering a condition that's going to
be adequately specific to avoid the card
feeling frustrating or uninteractable is
naturally going to be a big challenge. I
also choose a broader rule here because
I think the dragon is an example of a
frustratingly uninteractable design as
well, though to a lesser extent than
Edgar. Mana is one of the two primordial
resources of Magic the Gathering. And
discounting creatures is equivalent to
giving players an Eldrazi scion worth of
mana to spend every time they'd want to
cast one of those creatures. The
medallion cycle, which discounts spells
of a given color, are some of the most
powerful two mana artifacts in the game.
and the dragon puts a roughly equivalent
discount in the command zone. So a
dragon deck can get an entirely
impossible to stop accelerant to their
game plan and the rest of the table can
only do their best to deal with the
results of that acceleration. This can
pose a problem for players having fun in
the here and now. But there's also the
problem of what it does to the design
space of the game. And this is another
thing that comes up in the Commander
Chronicles episode. Dragons might cost a
lot now, but making a card type all cost
one less straight from the command zone
with no restrictions means that any
lowcost cards of that type in the future
that include any colorless symbols are
naturally going to have an outsized
impact on dragon decks. Watsi has kind
of fully committed to being careful with
this specifically with dragons since
they also recently printed Mox Jasper.
But in general, it's a bit reckless to
alter future design space in this way
with a type as frequently printed as
dragons. The design rule I'd set here is
simple. Eminence abilities should not
directly give cards or mana. Indirectly
is fine. All of the eminence abilities
are frequently used to generate cards,
mana, or both in their respective decks.
But there needs to be an extra step
involved to increase the specificity and
interactivity of this sort of ability.
Accumulating these primordial resources
is a massive part of most commander
decks. And giving a deck these resources
totally for free with no extra steps
gets you into really dangerous territory
for a deck feeling healthy and fitting
in. The dragon is considered a classic
pub stomper commander because it plays
dirtily battle cruiser magic in
principle, but its design is streamlined
to simply do that better than just about
any other deck can. And effortlessly
receiving mana is a big part of that. We
can also see this echoed in partner
commanders. Of the five partner
commanders that see the most competitive
EDH play, four of them directly give
cards or mana, and the fifth is used
indirectly with other cards to grant
cards and mana. This is especially the
case with partners because the mechanic
inherently grants card advantage. But
this is just an amplification of a
general trend. Of these five, the top
two are both two-color cards because
color is yet another modulating factor
that determines the power of a command
zone. More colors means more access to
powerful interaction and resource
engines. And while these are most seen
in CEDH, these effects of course bleed
into casual as well. If we look at the
three most popular commanders of the
past year, it's an easy to trigger card
draw engine, another easy to trigger
card draw engine, and a massive mana
granter. This is not to say that these
designs are bad or that it's never okay
to print cards with mana symbols or the
word draw or land on them. It's simply a
reflection that Wizards of the Coast
should be probably already knows to be a
little extra careful when it comes to
printing things that give direct
resources aimed at commander players.
whether eminence is involved or
otherwise. So, Eminence, should it
really be reprinted? My answer is yes,
because I think the design space is
interesting. The command zone is the
most unique part about the commander
format, and its quirks and weird little
nooks and crannies of possibility are
endlessly fascinating to me. It's for
the same reason that I sometimes find
myself drawn to the partner mechanic as
well, despite disliking it on a
conceptual level. And eminence is a far
more interesting set of nooks to be
explored further. There are some
strategies that just aren't as powerful
in commander. And it's nice to be able
to print a card that gives them a boost
without needing to fit the restrictions
of a conventional commander. There are
also lots of interesting design
possibilities that don't work without an
element that operates with a commander
in the command zone. Ripe design
territory for exploration. So, for the
rest of this video, I want to think
about some eminence designs that make
cool usage of the mechanic while
avoiding most of the elements that other
people find problematic. Earlier in this
video, I've gone through three rules I'd
follow when designing eminence cards.
Stick to two colors or less if there's
any risk of competing with existing
commanders. Aim for higher specificity
if there's any power concerned. And
avoid any eminence effect that directly
creates card or mana advantage. I'd also
add a fourth one here I didn't cover
earlier, but which kind of ties in with
the first. Eminence commanders should be
desirable to actually cast. The two
biggest offenders here are the
aforementioned Edgar Marov as well as
one I haven't talked about as much,
Inala. The issue with both of these is
that the text on the creature just isn't
that great an amplification of the
eminence effect. There are an endless
list of better things you could do with
one vampires for six mana than putting a
plus one plus1 counter on them. And
tapping wizards to drain opponents is an
even worse amplification of Inala's
valuec crunching ETB focused eminence
ability. So that'll be our final rule.
It needs to be desirable to cast the
creature. This is the commander format,
so you should be casting your commander.
Not casting an eminence commander also
betrays the purpose of the mechanic a
bit to me as well. It gives an
opportunity for the command zone to
offer multiple tiers of benefit. One
before your commander is in play and one
after. But this can't happen if you
never have a reason to ascend past that
first tier of power. So, we have our
rules, but what would I do with the
eminence mechanic? I mentioned aggro a
bit earlier and that's actually the
biggest area of opportunity I personally
see for Eminence. See, aggro is actually
challenging on a structural level with
regard to commanders themselves. There
are a bunch of fast deck styles that are
only propped up by the presence of a
somewhat fragile commander, leading to
glass cannon decks that are capable of
crushing players, but fall apart to two
removal spells. The commander allows the
deck to attain a high ceiling, but the
floor of the deck typically looks
pathetic in the landscape of a three
opponent 40 health format, leading to a
somewhat jarring play pattern. What
eminence does then is allow you to split
the difference with the eminence effect
boosting a deck's early game and overall
floor and the commander creature
offering a way to compound that
advantage in order to keep up a bit
later in the game. Arabo is one example,
but here's another I came up with with a
similar ability format. Instead of a
conventional Voltron commander you dump
all your resources into, how about an
eminence ability that reads, "At the
beginning of combat on your turn, you
may choose a creature you control. If
you do put a plus one plus1 counter on
it for each equipment attached to it,
then the creature itself could be stor
black human soldier with the text,"
"Whenever you attack, you may have
target attacking creature you control
deal damage equal to his power to any
target. If seven or more damage is dealt
this way, draw a card." The eminence
effect here can kick in early with
keywords like living weapon and formid
and it also works well alongside
especially low slung equipment bearers
like goblin gavalier or morio marauder.
This allows the deck to start putting on
pressure pretty early into the game and
encourages devoting more deck space to
lowcost stuff that might traditionally
scale poorly in the landscape of EDH.
The creature itself serves as a
follow-up piece that amplifies this once
the deck reaches five mana, effectively
amplifying the damage of the presumably
equipped and buffed largest attacker and
gaining card draw if that source of
damage was especially large. You could
also construct something spicier, more
along the lines of a torren or a sulf.
How about an eminence ability that
reads, "The first time a source you
control deals non-combat damage to a
single permanent or player each turn, it
deals that much damage plus one
instead." or power it up and give it a
condition. As long as you have
permanence of at least four different
types, whenever a source you control
would deal non-combat damage, it deals
that much damage plus one instead. Ends
up a little wordy once you add the
eminence clause, but you get the idea.
For both this last example and the
example of Sto's equipment based
eminence ability, I tried to put care
into making these abilities feel
interactable. Multiple non-land
permanence are required to be in play in
order for the effect to trigger, unlike
four of the six original Eminence
commanders whose ability is on a cast
trigger, an ETB trigger, or an upkeep
trigger. Sure, you still can't remove
the source of the effect here, but there
are certainly steps required to get
benefit from it and steps your opponents
can take to deny you that value. These
also both fall off big time if you don't
cast the commander. One extra
conditional damage isn't that great, and
a handful of plus one plus1 counters
each turn that you have to work for. and
which prevent you from using one of the
much better equipment commanders out
there also isn't that great. Aggro is
the biggest area that I like personally
as a way to utilize eminence due to the
mechanics early game emphasis and
stairsteppy nature, but that's far from
the only cool use case for it. There's a
lot of other interesting design niches
to be explored and the 33 Elk showed me
a handful of custom cards they'd made to
demonstrate those niches. You could have
an eminence ability offer a less
concrete resource such as goad and then
have the commander itself give a way to
more tangibly capitalize on goatated
creatures. You could have an eminence
ability that accumulates resources in
some way but with those resources only
being accessible by keeping the actual
card in play. Sort of like a riff on
experience counters that's more stable
and a bit less swingy. You could also
have an eminence ability that's actually
a downside with a strong commander that
mitigates that downside, allowing for
some truly unique designs and play
patterns. Alternatively, you could even
have a Bina style politicsy eminence
ability that can help any player with
the attached commander, allowing a
player to break parody and amplify the
benefit they get from it. All of these
show the potential of the mechanic. It
doesn't just have to be a powerful boost
to a creature type with an optional
attached creature. All sorts of cool and
elegant designs are possible here, and
attaining them requires above all else
mindset and restraint. I believe the
dragon and Edgar Marov were each made
with the idea to be a super cool,
powerful, perfectly rounded commander
for players who like the extremely
popular tribes of dragons and vampires,
respectively. This is how you create the
two most popular commanders of all time,
and in the process create cards that
have each commanded tripledigit price
tags for multiple months since the time
they were released. I also believe these
cards were mistakes, but that's because
crowning a powerful color soup champion
for two popular and iconic creature
types while simultaneously introducing a
spicy new command zone modification was
always going to be an inherently
challenging task. And it's one that just
so happened to be a poor pairing for
reasons I laid out earlier. A lot of
people have called eminence itself a
mistake or a bad mechanic. And those
people are half correct. Eminence is a
mechanic that is challenging to
implement well and which carries the
full possibility to easily veer off
course and into problems. But
importantly, that's only because the
mechanic poses such a fundamental
shakeup to the structure of the command
zone. And that feature of it also imbuss
it with a ton of rich gameplay
possibilities. One of the most
restrictive things about the commander
format is that decks often feel on or
off. Either the commander is in play or
it isn't. The eminence mechanic offers
the ability to bypass that to add
massive layers of dimension to
commanders, particularly ones that are
more aggressive. That's an incredible
tool and it's one I'd love to see used
again with care in the future.
Thanks for watching and thanks to
Architect for supporting the channel.
When I'm building decks with Architect,
I can easily add cards directly into any
of my categories, including one of my
baby board categories. If you want to
check out my decks, a link is in the
description. I'd also like to thank my
supporters, some of whom are on screen
now. Joining my Patreon or becoming a
YouTube member are the easiest ways to
support me in making higheffort videos
about the commander for and beyond. And
I greatly appreciate all the direct
support I get. With that said, I'll see
you next week where I'll be discussing
tax evasion commander style. I'm coming
for you a year ago.